Safety advocates had
the potentially hazardous
playground equipment removed.
A spokesperson stated that
“We’ll use every tool in
the sandbox to make
sure our kids are safe.”
The makers of
Johnny’s Li’l Blaster
have issued a recall
because the plastic projectiles
could be a choking hazard
for small children.
Large amounts of
dihydrogen monoxide
have been found in public pools
throughout the area.
We’ve assembled a task force...
Say adios to your salsa!
The FDA has recalled
the vegetable after a local
outbreak of tomato pox.
Want sauce on your pizza?
V8 in your Bloody Mary?
The city council immediately
banned the use of
motorized scooters after
a woman sprained her ankle.
[Councilman] We take safety very
seriously in this city and
we won’t stand for having a
dangerous product like this
out on the streets.
Where average, everyday citizens
could be hurt or victimized
by somebody who thinks it’s fun
to have these products and
whiz around all over the place.
Hey!
Second Amendment!